what could make frozen two even better
discovering all the clever ways it
recreated scenes from all the other
disney princess movies
we love the easter eggs that disney
hides in its movies but frozen too took
that idea even further by adding in
scenes that were directly inspired by
all those princess films of our
childhoods
get ready for all the feels as you take
a walk down that most regal of memory
lanes
we do this together okay i promise
we've all dreamed about having a fairy
godmother who can transform our lame old
outfits into something spectacular right
well it's not just cinderella that got
that treatment in the disney verse
elsa also got a sparkling new outfit
through magic too
while singing show yourself in otta
holland we love watching these two
scenes side by side and seeing just how
similar
they are disney definitely wanted true
fans to notice the shout out to the 1950
animated movie
but there's an important difference
between these glittering dress makeovers
that shows just how different
modern elsa is to the classic disney
princesses
although cinderella is pretty handy with
a sewing machine she can't actually make
her ripped pink dress into a glittering
blue ball gown
instead she needs the fairy godmother to
throw out a bibbidi-bobbidi-boo
and wave a wand elsa on the other hand
has such strong powers that she doesn't
need anyone else to make her fashion
dreams come true
she's a sister doing it for herself just
check out that diamond effect
what a glow up you look different did
you cut your hair or something
or something there's another obvious
moment when frozen 2 pays homage to a
previous disney princess film during a
song
when elsa finishes up into the unknown
she throws down her arms and the sky
fills with glittering runes those
diamond shapes featured in the trailer
and we were all instantly reminiscing
about one of the most beautiful scenes
in any recent disney princess movie
the lantern festival entangled of course
and that takes place against a song too
i see the light fair enough those
lanterns float slowly and calmly upwards
whereas elsa's diamond runes jaggedly
appear
instantly and rapunzel is having a
romantic moment with her bae
while elsa is all alone facing a
dangerous calling
but you know a sky full of magical
bright lights is a sky full of magical
bright lights right
elsa brings them out again when she
sings show yourself just before she gets
that sparkly cinderella style fashion
transformation
air fire water earth
it's another background setting that
frozen 2 pays homage to in relation to
brave
and another moment from the trailer that
caught everyone's attention and in fact
another link to those runes we're
talking of course about the stones that
guard the entrance to the enchanted
forest
they're so reminiscent of the stone
circle and brave right that's an
important place for merida just like the
enchanted forest
is important for elsa this forest is
beautiful
[Music]
looking back at your childhood you might
remember being scared out of your wits
when snow white ran through the deep
dark woods
she's plenty of terrified after all and
you might well have blocked that scene
from your memory as it's pretty dark for
a kid's film
but frozen 2 brings it back in a lighter
funnier way by recreating all those
creepy eyes shining out in the forest
during olaf's musical number when i'm
older
the plucky snowman proves he's not
totally naive by looking pretty freaked
out by the creepy eyes
his smile drops and he says excuse me
as he quickly leaves the dark scary part
of the forest but he sure
isn't as terrified as snow white when
the huntsman tells her to run away and
hide in the woods
snow white is understandably already
freaking out about the fact that her
stepmom once are gone for good
so it's not surprising she freaks out so
hard when she's surrounded by a bunch of
creepy eyes
first she sees an angry owl's eyes then
a bunch of bats yellow eyes
and then a load of psychedelic tree eyes
yep
freaky there's a blink and you'll miss
it recreated scene from beauty and the
beast that only mega fans might have
spotted in frozen too
it harks back to when gaston's fighting
the beast we see gaston hold a weapon
over beast ted who has his back to the
villain and is unarmed
this is reimagined and frozen too in the
scene when elsa discovers what really
happened to her grandfather
she sends the ice sculpture tableau to
anna of king renard holding a weapon
over the head of northuldra's leader
and just like the beast he's got his
back to the villain and is unarmed
that's my grandfather attacking
the north uldra leader if you want to
see how frozen tube recreates a moment
from mulan you have to look pretty hard
but you can see a parallel between horse
riding scenes in the two films
remember that avalanche scene in mulan
where she rides khan against the snow
pounding down the mountainside it looks
like waves of white pouring down
and when elsa rides knock across the
water to save arendelle from the tidal
wave heading its way
the frothy white waves look like snow
we've seen recreations of familiar
scenes so far but frozen 2
also references disney princess movies
with a more traditional easter egg
approach
like when elsa goes back into the past
when she's in auto holland and sees her
parents in their younger years
the little mermaid moment happens when
the future king is sitting in a tree
looking at a book
what are you reading your majesty some
new danish author the author in question
is hans christian anderson and the book
cover has a silhouette of a mermaid on a
rock
so it's clearly anderson's the little
mermaid novel and the author
also wrote the snow queen which frozen
is based on so that's double easter eggs
right there
with all those nature spirits knocking
about and frozen too it was an easy
opportunity to link up with moana and
naturally the link is going to be water
when agnar is telling little anna and
elsa about the enchanted forest at the
beginning of the movie
we see how the north soldier people
catch a ride on the water
moana has that kind of relationship with
the ocean too of course
and you can see the link back to that
2016 film particularly when you think
about toddler moana getting a lift on a
wave
oh the little cutie
the canoe scene from frozen two grabbed
our attention right from the trailer but
it also might have grabbed your
attention if you loved watching
pocahontas when you were little
apart from singing the classic tunes you
probably wished you could be the main
character having fun on the water
and frozen 2 clearly pays homage to the
waterfall drop during pocahontas's song
just around the river bend
olaf's reaction is pretty much like miko
the raccoon's horror at falling down the
falls but ana's scared reaction is
pretty different to pocahontas's delight
to be fair though anna and olaf's
waterfall is a longer drop
and elsa sent them off without their
permission pocahontas was totally in
control of her adventure and loving
every minute
he wants me to be steady
[Music]
like the river from a perilous moment to
an adorable moment
next up is the way frozen 2 recreated
the opening of the princess and the frog
both movies in fact open with the main
characters as little girls
tiana's mom is reading her and charlotte
a fairy tale which charlotte is loving
because of all the romance
remind you of anyone yep she's just like
anna
rather than their mom it's on an elsa's
dad who's telling them the story of the
enchanted forest
but there are so many parallels between
the two scenes this has to be a
deliberate link to the princess and the
frog
those wide-eyed expressions and ana
swooning back just like charlotte
whoa papa that was epic
it's a shame that frozen 2 didn't
recreate one of princess jasmine scenes
from aladdin but it does include a bit
of that 1992 movie in a fun way
remember when aladdin escapes from the
cave of wonders it's a pretty wild ride
and elsa copies one of his moves when
she slides down the ice tunnel while
singing show yourself
it's just like the moment aladdin zooms
down the stairs turned slide
start panicking we're finishing up with
sleeping beauty
yes we wish there was a recreated aurora
scene too but the way frozen 2 paid
homage to the 1959 movie was actually
through a setting
if the enchanted forests look familiar
to you that's because it's totally based
on the forest and sleeping beauty
the animators were inspired by artists
ivan earl's backgrounds and colors in
aurora's forest
right down to the tree groups and
vertical lines
[Music]
so now that you've seen all the evidence
do you think frozen 2
is the ultimate disney princess movie as
it includes all the other films that
came before it or does that title go to
ralph breaks the internet when vanellope
meets all the princesses
sound off in the comment section and hit
that like button to show your love for
all things frozen
thanks for watching
you